happy Halloween it's that time again to
talk to you about the latest games in
new releases and this week a lowly
employee of fisco becomes a zombie
battling bad ass in sunset overdrive
this insanely saturated quirky world
combines ridiculous weaponry like the
compensator with ridiculous bosses like
this guy start grinding October 28 also
this week we get the terrifying murder
machine harken I mean just look at that
guy's death stare it looks like eats
bricks for breakfast in this hack and
slash RPG the world is covered in evils
they let loose the biggest baddest
tattoo face guy that got the more
enemies you kill the higher your XP
multiplier will go but you gotta bank
your XP at checkpoints encouraging you
to take risks to gain even more XP
because if you die you gotta go get it
and that ghost fades over time so you
gotta go get it quickly take on the
demonic realm October 28th
don't forget about WWE 2015 we're
leopard print tights and Kid Rock never
go out of style but last gen gets into
the ring first with current gen coming
out in the next month you get two
different Hulk Hogan's NWO version and
regular Hulk the Undertaker RVD and
Ryback and all your other favorites with
the soundtrack handpicked by John Cena
it's going to be a hell of a ride pick
it up and take them down October 28th
NBA Live comes out to play this week
showing off some updated graphics and
player models they've added more than a
hundred animations to make the game a
little bit more lively entertaining than
last year the game also boasts smarter
AI and transition game for 48 minutes
and 94 feet of end and dynamic gameplay
check out those sick layups when the
game comes out october twenty a also
this week the unfinished swan
transitions from PlayStation Plus to ps4
and Vita allowing you to smear black
pain all over the place to uncover all
sorts of amazing mechanics and locations
in the process if you've never played it
before it's a great time to discover a
game that transports you to a land where
anything seems possible be sure to check
it out on the twenty-third finally
dungeon of the endless leaves early
access and into full-on game territory
where a player and their team of Heroes
protect the generator of a crash ship
all while exploring an ever-expanding
dungeon also while facing hordes of
monsters and special events that can
kill you sounds like a great time this
fresh mix of roguelike and tower defense
is yours the price is right grab the
game and a great track by flyby no
October 27 for further details visit
gamespot com release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change see you next week